hello and welcome to another fundamental
investing tutorial with use of
programming where we left off we were
generating this chart here well we would
hit hit Ryan we currently are picking
this stock
anyways generates this chart as you can
see we've got some empty fields now that
we're going to populate with some data
from quantal so that's what we're doing
in this video and then in the next video
we'll incorporate everything all
together into the screener
and then it will display all this
information on the company that it finds
so close out of here so all we really
need to do is go over to our Kwon de
Lappe location and basically we just
need to copy and paste everything so
from here since the what's being run
here is graph data eventually we can
change the name of this function but
we're really just throwing everything
under this single function which really
you could have different functions and
bring them all together but we're just
going to hack this together so anyway
it's all gonna be under the same graph
data function you know obviously we've
got the compute MACD exponential moving
average typical moving average and the
RSI functionality we're going to take
this cuando part and also put it under
graph data at least for now that makes
the most sense because this is also just
purely graphing data now once we
incorporate the the screening what it'll
do is it'll screen find a company and
then that company it'll throw in at the
stock variable here so it'll make sense
it's just we have one really large large
function here so anyway what we're gonna
do is come up here basically take this
stock variable and throw it into and
just interchange it with ticker so all
we need to do is just put that really
starting here underneath this try so
that's what we're gonna do so we're
going to take this and copy and paste
all the way down to the point but right
before it defines
because obviously we're not gonna graph
that graph so copy that and then come
over here underneath this try paste now
we need to realign everything so come
back up to that try and align everything
should just take a single tab now if
you'll notice we because of our Kuantan
I trying to accept loop really came down
to an exception here which came after
after plottings but what we can do is
just copy and paste this exception come
over here and we need to paste the
exception here and have this over save
that and now it's pulling the quantal
data and stuffing it into these very
well yeah these these variables here and
so now we can actually plot those
variables so we'll come down to those
axes we just created and start plotting
that data so here we'll say a x3 dot
plot and here we'll plot the income date
and income and then we're also gonna do
a color and that color I think we should
steal it from Mac the MACD function
probably is the best one see where we
were plotting MACD here we'll take this
color this for EE 6fd and come back down
here color and that's the color that
we'll plot and then finally the other
thing that we want to do is plot y label
and since we don't have much space I'm
just going to short hand every labels
this we ni for net income color of that
label will be white and then what we're
gonna do is just copy this here come
down here paste we'll change this to a X
4 X 4 is going to apply it Rev date and
revenue this will be rubbish or and then
down here we will apply it
ROC right yeah Aros I think it was ROC
underscore or under Kasem ROC date
followed by ROC and then this is ROC
color wine well that's the same so let's
make sure let's see where we stand at
the mo yeah other thing we need to do I
don't think we changed the right so what
this is doing is its throwing stock and
we were initially it's not instead of
stock we were calling for or asking for
ticker ticker can just be replaced by
stock now the last thing to take just in
case someone entered an under case or a
lower case stock it would fail this link
were requires it's a case sensitive link
so we need to add in a stock dot upper
so we'll copy this paste paste now
hopefully withs application it's
possible that something went wrong
stuffing it all together like this but
this should run and populate so stock to
plot gotta know and spit out everything
so it's probably working out sure enough
here we go as you can see we have more
finance data than we do price data but
we can't just zoom in and now you have
it's over you know your revenue line
your return on capital line and your net
income line and of course you can also
get a you know from the hover the mouse
over on here
you can't hover your mouse and actually
get this exact number so you don't even
really need the numbers over here at all
the other thing I wouldn't mind doing is
adding in the grids so we could add in a
grid to this so back down to the bottom
and so you could say ax 3 grid inning
here you quit true paste that here make
four and paste it again and make it a x5
run it whoo oh shoot
yeah it doesn't have any colors that's
black but what we can do is if you want
the grid to show it would be a X what
grid and then then what you need to do
is say color equals and whatever color
in this case we want to do white paste
and paste this time we should have grids
on there yep okay so now we've got the
grids we've got everything marked the
only thing that we really want to do
well at the very end I can show you guys
we'll possibly throw in a little
function to cut the off the excess here
so it's just you know this data here but
we'll get to that the next thing that I
really want to do is first we should
connect this to our actual screening
program so that's what we're going to do
in the next video and stuff that all
together so stay tuned to the next video
as always thanks for the support and the
subscriptions and until next time